throughout these difficult and complex
negotiations with the European Union I
have had one goal in mind to honor the
vote of the British people and deliver a
good brexit deal last week we achieved a
decisive breakthrough when we agreed
with the European Commission the terms
for our smooth and orderly exit from the
EU alongside that withdrawal agreement
we published an outline political
declaration setting out the framework
for our future relationship last night
in Brussels I had a good detailed
discussion with President Juncker
in which I set out what was needed in
that political declaration to deliver
for the United Kingdom
we tasked our negotiating teams to
continue working overnight and as a
result the text of that declaration has
been agreed between the European Union
and the United Kingdom I've just updated
the cabinet on progress and I'll be
making a statement to the House of
Commons later this afternoon
this is the right deal for the UK it
delivers on the vote of the referendum
it brings back control of our borders
our money and our laws and it does so
while protecting jobs protecting our
security and protecting the integrity of
the United Kingdom the agreement we've
reached is between the UK and the
European Commission it is now up to the
27 leaders of the other EU Member States
to examine this agreement in the days
leading up to the special EU council
meeting on Sunday I will be speaking to
my counterparts over that time including
meeting Chancellor Kurtz of Austria here
in Downing Street later today last night
I spoke to the Spanish Prime Minister
Pedro Sanchez and I'm confident that on
Sunday we'll be able to agree a deal
that delivers for the whole UK family
including Gibraltar on Saturday I will
return to Brussels for further meeting
with president Jonker way we will
discuss how to bring this process to a
conclusion in the interests of all our
people the British people want this to
be settled they want a good deal that
sets us
on course for a brighter future that
deal is within our grasp and I am
determined to deliver it